اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في هذه النافذه للتحليل
العسكري لمجريات حرب اسرائيل على قطاع غزه
وفيها نستضيف كالمعتاد المحلل العسكري
اللواء فايز الدويري نتابع بدايه اخر
تطورات المشهد ميدانيا على الخريطه
التفاعليه معك عبد القادر عراضه تفضل نعم
ليلى ولعلي سانطرح من تصريحات لافته لرئيس
الاركان الاسرائيلي رئيس الاركان
الاسرائيلي كما نقلت القناه الثال ع
الاسرائيليه
حذر مما سماه ضياع منجزات الجيش
الاسرائيلي بالنظر الى غياب اي خطه
للمرحله التي تلي ما بعد الحرب على غزه
لعل في هذه التصريحات يرتبط بتطورات
الميدانيه تابعنا عمليه القصف بالصواريخ
التي طالت مناطق في غلاف غزه القسام كانت
قد اعلنت عن استهداف انتي فوت البارحه
كانت رايا القدس قد استهدفت سديروت اذا
الصواريخ لازالت قادره على ان تنطلق
واللافت انها تنطلق من المناطق الشماليه
هذه المناطق التي كانت محور جدل خلال
اليومين الماضيين بالنظر الى سحب الفرقه
رقم 36 من هذه المناطق لكن لو ذهبنا
بالتفصيل الى منطقه الشمال واخر تطوراتها
اخر عاجل كنا تابعناه هو اعلان كتائب
القسام عن استهداف اليات في اليات عسكريه
اسرائيليه بقذائف الهاون وذلك في منطقه
التفاح في في شرق مدينه غزه ياتي هذا
التطور بينما كان هناك قصف اسرائيلي مكتف
على جباليا ومخيم جباليه لكن كان هناك
حديث اليوم في هذا اليوم الثاني بعد المئه
عن اشتباكات ل قضتها كتائب القسام في
مناطق عديده نحن نتحدث عن ابراج الكرامه
وابراج المخابرات ولكن ايضا الشيخ رضوان
اللافت في الشيخ رضوان هو حديث القسام
كتائب القسام عن استهدافها لنقله جند
اسرائيليه بعبوه شواد ولكن ايضا بقذيفه من
نوع الياسين في هذه المنطقه في الشيخ
رضوان ايضا استهدفت ناقلات جند هنا في
منطقه تل الهوا ب في المناطق الغربيه
لمدينه غزه اذا ا تطورات لافته في هذه
الجبهه الشماليه القصف ايضا طال منطقه
الدراج اذا جبهه شماليه لا زالت تردنا
اخبارها رغم حديث الجيش الاسرائيلي عن
عمليه انتشار جديده وسحب كما قلت الفرقه 3
من هذه المنطقه لو ذهبنا الى المنطقه
الوسطى لعل ابرز ما فيها هو بالتحديد في
منطقه المغازي التي تعرضت الى قصف مكثف
ذلك لا يعني بان مناطق بريج والنصيرات
والزوايده لم تكن عرضه لهذا القصف لكنه
كان اخف اليوم لكن المغازي تحصي شهدائها
الذين ينتشلون من تحت الانقاض بعد ان
استهدفت با ايضا بقذائف او ب مقذوفات
فسفوريه او قنابل فسفوريه بالذهاب الى
المنطقه الجنوبيه وهنا التطور اللافت وكان
ضمن العواجل التي تناولناها قبل قبل قليل
وهي عمليات القصف الاسرائيلي لكن هذا
القصف الاسرائيلي هذه المره وفق اخر
الاخبار طال المناطق الغربيه لخان يونس
بعد ان كانت المناطق الشرقيه والجنوبيه
الشرقيه هي المسرح الرئيسي لعملي القصف
والاشتباكات كتائب القسام تحدثت عن عمليه
استهداف لاليات عسكريه في المناطق الشرقيه
ولكن ايضا في المناطق الجنوبيه الشرقيه من
خلال استهداف اليتين وجرف هنا في المناطق
الجنوبيه مع عمليه القصف كما قلت التي
طالت معا ولكن ايضا طالت مناطق في الجنوب
الشرقي تطورات على اكثر من صعيد تاتي ايضا
مع قصه الانفاق وحديث صحيفه امريكيه نقلا
عن مسؤولين امريكيين واسرائيليين عن حاله
انبهار واندهاش مما تم رصده من هذه
الانفاق ليله خصوصا ما تعلق بطولها وايضا
ما تعلق
بكفاءه انجاز هذه الانفاق ولعلكم في
التحليل سيتم تطرق الى هذه الج نطرق الى
كل هذه النقاط ولكن مهم جدا ان نبدا
بالاشتباكات عبد القادر شكرا جزيلا لك على
تفسيرها وتوضيحها على الخارطه اللواء فايز
اهلا بك من جديد اذا الحديث عن جبهه
شماليه لم تهدا وهذا اقل ما
يقال ما الخطا الذي ارتكبته اسرائيل والذي
يجعل كل هؤلاء العسكريين ينتقدون نت هناك
وجهات نظر
متباينه رئيس الاركان له وجهه نظر وزير
الدفاع له وجهه نظر مختلفه بن كفير يتحدث
بمقار مختلفه كليا الى غير ذلك وحتى بعض
الجنرالات
الاحتياط الان ناخذ الحكي الحديث الرسمي
للمسؤولين عن المعركه اذا لا اتوقف عند
حديث بن كفير لانه لا يرقى لمستوى اصلا
مناقشته
نتحدث ماذا قال وزير الدفاع وماذا قال
رئيس الاركان وزير الدفاع تحدث عن انجاز
المهمه وبالتالي تم السيطره تم تدمير 700
منصه اطلاق تم قتل 9000 من قوات القسام من
اصل 14000 تم تدمير شبكه الانفاق الى غير
ذلك هذه المعطيات التي
امامه جعلته يتحدث بهذا الشكل سواء كانت
معلومات مزيفه ضلله صادقه بغض النظر هو
اتخذ القرار بناء على معطيات معينه ترجم
هذا القرار باجراءات على
الارض تم سحب الثلاثه فرق
اي عراضه تحدث عن سحب الفرقه 36 لا الفرقه
36 سحبت مبكرا التي سحبت الفرق التي
المتبقي لانه كان هناك ثلاث فرق لانه
الفرقه 36 سحبت قبل اسابيع ونقلت نقلت من
الشمال الى اتذكر جيدا عندما تم الاعلان
وقتها والسؤال عن الكل يتذكر عندما تم سحب
الكتيبه 13 من لواء جولاني لواء جولاني
يتبع الفرقه 36 عندما تم سحب هذه القوه
وتم اعاده تاهيلها تم ارسالها الى منطقه
الوسط وكانت هي المسؤوله عن معارك
المخيمات وبقي في المنطقه الرقتين هذه
الفرق سحبت الى داخل الغلاف على عمق خمس
الى 15 م يتم اعاده بنائها ولكنها بوضعيه
استعداد
قتالي الان هذا الاستعداد القتالي يتم
الزج بوحدات منها في اتجاهات محدده في
اوقات محدده بناء على معطيات محدده هذه
المعطيات تتمثل بظهور مقاتلين الحصول على
معلومات لانه طائرات الاستطلاع كوات
كابتور
وبقيه طائرات الدرون والطائرات
العموديه الاقمار الصناعيه الكل يغذي بنك
المعلومات عندما تظهر معطيات تتعلق
بالانفاق تتعلق بالرهاب تتعلق
بالمقاتلين الان يتم الزج بهذه القوات
ويتم العوده الى القصف الناري لهذا السبب
خلال 24 ساعه لاحظنا اتساع دائره القصف
واتساع دائره تدخل القوات الان عندما دخل
ماذا كانت النتيجه يعني التي اثبتت خطا
طروحات وزير الدفاع انط الصواريخ على مدار
ثلاث ايام اول امس امس اليوم كان 50 صاروخ
وقسم منها اطلق من بيت حانون فبالتالي
ترسخت القناعه ان المعطيات التي بني عليها
تصريح وزير الدفاع ما لم يكن تصريحا مسيسا
بانها معلومات خاطئه ماذا كان راي الاخر
رئيس الاركان اشار في احد المقاربات بانه
لا يستبعد هو ليس الان في صدد التنفيذ قال
لا يستبعد عوده عمليه عسكريه موسعه في
الشمال لانه هناك مؤشرات على قدره حماس
على اعاده تنظيم وبناء قوتها مره اخرى اذا
ما ترجم هذا الامر وجسد على ارض الواقع
يعني ان عجله القتال ستتسع وسنعود نتحدث
عن القاطع الشمالي يبدو ان هذه ليست
الحسابات الخاطئه الوحيده لاسرائيل هناك
حسابات خاطئه تتعلق بشبكات الانفاق
والدليل هذه المفاجات بالنسبه لهم التي
يعبرون عنها ولكن قبل ان نتحدث عن ذلك
اريد ان اتحدث عن الاشتباكات في المنطقه
الوسطى والجنوبيه اليوم الاشتباكات في
المنطقه الوسطى بالامس كثر الحديث حول سحب
الفرقه 36 لكن ما جرى بالامس هو اكمال
الانسحاب بدء الانسحاب بدا منذ ايام
وتحدثنا عنه في معظم اللقاءات لانه قبل
تقريبا ما يقارب الاسبوع تم اسناد المهم ت
اداره المعركه الى الفرقه
99 وتم الابقاء على الفرقه 36 بدور
الاحتياط الداعم للفرقه تس لماذا لانه
الفرقه 36 انهكت ولحق بها خسائر جسيمه في
معركه الشمال اعاده تاهيلها لم تكن كافيه
تم الزج بها في هذه المعركه فشلت في معركه
الوسط لم تحقق انجازات تم نقل مسؤوليه
اداره المعركه ل الفرقه 99 ما هو الاختلاف
الفرقه 36 فرقه مدرعه فيها لوائين نظامي
مدرعه فيها لواء احتياط مدرع فيها لواء
جولاني بينما الفرقه 99 لا مختلف تنظيمها
فيها لواء مدرع واحد فيها لواء مظليين
فيها لواء اي نخبه مشاه فبالتالي هنا
طبيعه المعركه تتطلب
تغيير نوع القوات يعني يجب ان يتوفر عنصر
المشا وعص نصر قوات النخبه لانه هنا اربعه
اهداف يمكن عزلها وقد تم عزلها وبالتالي
الان المعارك في المنطقه الوسط هي معارك
مستقله نجد معركه لو سمحت خارطه الوسط نجد
البريج يقاتل ككتله واحده المغازي ككتله
واحده الزواده ككتله واحده الصيرات ككتله
واحده لكن ماذا يجري الان البريج هو
العقبه الرئيسيه يعني رغم مرور اسابي لا
تزال القوات عاجزه عن الدخول البريج
باستثناء حوالي 600 متر من الجنوب ان
سيرات لا اقول توقفت المعارك لكن تحولت
الى القصف لعدم القدره على الدخول الى
انسرات في الزوايد صغير تم احاطته تم
الدخول من الشمال الغربي الى منطقه
الحديقه في المغازي تم الدخول من الشمال
الغربي كذلك الى عمق معين واقتطاع جزء
معين منه لانه حجم مساحته صغيره اذا ذهبنا
جنوبا نعم وهنا طبعا هنا في ه المنطقه تم
السيطره او ال وضع اليد على شارع صلاح
الدين الحديث عن
انتقال التركيز من ال من الغرب الى
الشرق هنا يعني ما هي دلالته هنا السبب
منطقه القراره اوزنه تقريبا مر عليها اي
تقريبا اسبوع قتال ضاري جدا تم تدمير
مظاهر الحياه والبنيه التحتيه لكن عجزت
القوات عن دخولها والسيطره عليها او
التواجد بها فتم سحب القوات من القراره
والزن الى منطقه كفيم لاعاده التاهيل في
منطقه خسا كان هناك لواء مظليين يعمل كذلك
هذا اللواء فشل في دخول المنطقه و ووقع به
خسائر كبيره اجبروا على سحبه الى خلف
السياج لاعاده تاهيله تبقى منطقه المنطقه
الواسعه عبسان الجديده عبسان الكبيره بني
سهيله لا يزال هناك مقتربات الدخول من
اقصى الشمال واقصى الجنوب وتوقفت قبل شارع
صلاح الدين اذا سمحت اشرنا شارع صلاح
الدين ناتي الى مدينه خانيونس ل جلها او
معظمها يقع غرب طريق صلاح
الدين فشلت معظم المحاولات للدخول
باستثناء الدخول من المنطقه الغربيه من
منطقه جوش قطيف وال المواصي ودخلت الى
ثلاثه نقاط لا يزال القتال يستمر في
النقاط الثلاثه وهي المحطه والسجن
والكتيبه انما كان هناك محاوله احاطه من
الجنوب من منطقه الفخاري باتجاه قازان
النجار وهذه المحاولات لا تزال تراوح
مكانها طبعا الاشتباكات دائما تحظى بنصيب
الاسد لان هذا ما يحدث في الميدان ولكن
مهم ايضا ان نتحدث عن ما اشارت اليه
النيويورك تايمز اليوم طبعا هذا رقم
افتراضي تتحدث عن شبكه الانفاق بانها اكبر
مما كان متوقعا كانت تتحدث عن ارقام مثل
500 م الان تتحدث عن 600 الى 720 ماذا
يعني هذا تحديدا حتى هذه المعلومات اللي
قدمتها النيويورك تايمز هي مبنيه على
معلومات من داخل الكيان الاسرائيلي يعني
النيويورك تايمز مصادرها اسرائيليه
وبالتالي الان التباينات حول اكثر من
نقطه اطوال
الانفاق لاطوال الانفاق كانت تقدر بالحد
الاقصى 530 ل 570 الان الحد الادنى 560
والحد الاعلى 700
الحديث عن طبيعه تركيب الانفاق طابق
طابقين ثلاث طوابق نوعيه مواد البناء التي
استخدمت في اعداد الانفاق والاهم من
ذلك اعداد الانفاق لادوار محدده قتاليه
وفتحات الانفاق واللي تقدر بحوالي 5700
فتحه وما زالت اسرائيل ت تعرب عن دهشتها
ومفاجاتها في الندق الا الصندوق الاسود
الذي اشرت اليه مرارا شكرا جزيلا لك
اللواء فاز دويري